what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
zeke's beast titan and its true power if
you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you can do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know let me know in
the comments if you want to see a
similar video for one of the other titan
shifters where i break down their own
strengths
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and while
you wait for the next attack on time
video to drop feel free to check out our
growing attack on time playlist where we
got videos about all the titan shifters
and their powers explained all the
acronyms and their powers explained that
titans rank from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all the really interesting thing
about zeke's beast titan is how much
stronger it
is than previous versions of the beast
titan as we now know
the beast titan user gets animal based
powers but they're not necessarily
ape-based
like zeke's are there were past users
who could transform into an alligator
titan a reindeer titan or even a flying
bird titan
tom xaver was the beast titan before
zeke and although we don't know what his
specific
animal was we do know that his titan
wasn't useful in combat
even though he was a titan shifter he
focused on titan research rather than on
titan combat
as a result you can bet that the nation
of marley
must have been ecstatic when they got to
know zeke's version of the beast titan
which was very
very useful in combat in fact zeke's
titan was arguably the most useful titan
that marlei had at their disposal
with the possible exception of the
colossal titan whose explosive
transformations allowed him to create
giant nuclear-like explosions although
the colossal titan was called the god of
destruction
zeke also had a special alias marlei
called him the boy wonder
and he was referred to as marlei's
strongest warrior and he wasn't called
the boy wonder because he helped batman
solve crimes but because his royal blood
gave him special bonus abilities like
all beast titans he had the animal
powers and for zeke his ape-like powers
were very useful on their own
his pitching assault aka throwing
ability was called an unprecedented
awe-inspiring weapon
but that's not what made him the boy
wonder rather it was the power hidden in
his blood by injecting other ldns with
his spinal fluid
he could turn them into titans who
obeyed him although not always perfectly
the trigger for turning these aldeans
into titans was zeke's scream
additionally as if he wasn't op enough
already it's also been confirmed that
zeke's titan can also use selective
hardening like many other titans
when zeke's 17 meter titan is first
noticed by mike
zecharias humanity's second strongest
soldier after levi
zacharias is immediately concerned he's
never seen a titan covered in hair like
some sort of beast before
and he's right to be concerned the beast
titan lifts his horse
and throws it at zacharias who manages
to dodge
only to get caught by a nearby titan the
beast titan speaks
which is by the way another
distinguishing feature of zeke's titan
compared to most other titan shifters
who cannot speak in their titan forms
other notable titan speakers include
peak's card titan and to a lesser extent
emir's jaw titan zeke tells the titan to
wait and stop eating zacharias
but this titan doesn't follow his
instructions too well and continues to
hurt humanity's second strongest soldier
after zeke kills this titan he fluently
speaks with mike
questioning him but the second strongest
soldier is too shocked to respond
after zeke takes his vertical
maneuvering gear he tells the
surrounding titans that they can move
now
and they rush in to finish off mike so
as far as introductions go
this was an insane one for many reasons
one this titan could actually talk and
two
he could effortlessly kill the second
strongest soldier humanity within the
walls had
not to mention he could accurately throw
a horse however this was only the
beginning and zeke proves to be more and
more formidable as the story goes on
from here
not only is this beast titan clearly
intelligent from the get-go unlike most
titans people have seen up to this point
we later find out from a data book that
he's actually one of the most
intelligent beings in the show
perhaps the most intelligent he scored
an off the charts 11 out of 10
in intelligence a score he shared with
hanji so he's not just strong he's very
smart too
and his titan strength combined with his
genius level intellect make him all the
more deadly
in chapter 70 we see that the beast
titan effortlessly overpowered reiner's
armored titan
he completely shattered the armor this
is just one of many instances that hype
up the power of the beast's titan and
although the fight itself is not shown
we can assume that the beast titan
likely used his throwing ability to
break through the armor he would go on
to use his throwing ability to easily
wipe
out a charging army with crushed rocks
and later to wipe out an enemy nation's
navy fleet
so clearly most titans fighters and even
armies
are no match for him but what happens
when zeke comes up against someone as
strong as levi
and ackerman and humanity's strongest
soldier zeke and levi have multiple
fights over the course of the story
levi known as humanity's strongest
soldier vs zeke known as marley's
strongest warrior it is one of the most
intense rivalries in the series
now let's see which one comes out on top
the first battle is not even close
levi used irwin and the army's
distraction to sneak up on zeke
and by the time zeke notices him it's
way too late levi absolutely wrecks the
beast titan not even giving him enough
time to harden
levi clearly won the battle but he was
also caught off guard
when pique's card titan showed up the
kartain's incredible speed allowed her
to save zeke
and so that made the score 1-0 in favor
of levi
because zeke obviously had to run away
and retreat one thing to consider here
is that the beast titan was caught off
guard by levi who closed the distance
between them before zeke knew what hit
him however zeke's beast titan actually
excels in long distance battles where he
can utilize throws
along with other titans so although levi
is clearly superior in close
distance combat we were left to wonder
after this first fight what would happen
if these two had a rematch
where a more experienced zeke saw levi
coming in advance
then fast forward to aaron and the rest
attacking marley
zeke space titan appears and gets taken
down in no time flat by levi later we
find out that this was not a real fight
but a pre-planned thing the goal was for
zeke a royal-blooded titan shifter and
aaron to come together
so they could unlock the full power of
the founding titan thus
zeke was willingly taken back to
paradise island however instead of
letting zeke and air and do whatever
they wanted
levi takes zeke to the titan forest zeke
is being treated as more of a hostage
than an ally
finally wanting to get to aaron who was
also locked up after deciding to attack
marley on his own without getting
permission
zeke tries to escape his spinal fluid
was in the line that the soldiers
surrounding him drank
and thus he screams turning everyone
except levi into mindless titans he can
control
the previous fellow soldiers now attack
levi in their titan forms and levi is
devastated emotionally it crushes him
that he needs to kill them as if he
hasn't lost enough friends and men
because of zeke he now has to kill his
remaining soldiers before they kill him
again here's a situation where zeke uses
his intelligence not to mention his lack
of morals rather than
pure strength in an attempt to defeat
levi and it seems to work at first
levi is surrounded by titans who are
faster and move differently than normal
titans showing that zeke
can create stronger than average titans
making him all the deadlier
zeke in the meantime uses his titan
controlling powers to get a titan to
pick him up the plan is for the titan to
carry him to aaron
the fact that he trusts himself in the
hands of one of his titans
shows that he is confident in his
ability to control it however
never underestimate levi who drenched
with titan blood
manages to catch up to zeke and uses
thunder spears to break through his
heart and nape and at this point it
seems clear that in a straightforward
battle
levi is stronger he'll win and has every
time humanity's strongest soldier came
out on top against marley's strongest
warrior but levi doesn't make sure to
kill him here and because of that the
battle was over but not the war
levi tied zeke to a thundersphere in
such a way that it would detonate
if zeke moved and thus his body would be
blown apart
however again levi underestimated zeke
zeke purposely detonates his body badly
injuring levi
levi was actually thought to be dead for
a long time after this moment
and to this day he hasn't recovered to
the caliber of fighter he once was yet
zeke whose body was split in two
made a full recovery and this was an
important aspect of his power
because he was royal blooded amir fritz
from the world of paths
served him and saved him i explained
this in my recent all 20 titan shifters
in their powers explained video
if you want more info but emir fritz the
first and founding titan
was actually a slave of the royal family
before and after her death in the real
world and she had a titan place
zeke into its titan body and from there
he was healed from an injury that
probably would have killed any non-royal
blooded titan shifter she remolded his
whole body out of the special earth in
the unknown land
where it felt like zeke was there for
years but also like he was only there
for an instant
it is a land that transcends time and
all titan transformations and
regeneration
come from emir's work in this unknown
land in this different but related plane
of existence
so because of his royal blood zeke
actually ended up coming out on top
in this final exchange with levi at this
point it seems like he could have
virtually recovered from any wound
because emir was serving him
and so with his throwing abilities
intelligence titan control and practical
unkillability it is not far-fetched to
say that he was arguably the strongest
titan shifter at this point especially
since aaron had yet to unlock the
founding titan's powers
then for a second zeke was even more
powerful
when he made contact with aaron and they
entered the unknown land where amir was
at this point it was revealed that zeke
and aaron had different goals
zeke wanted to give every ld in a body
that will never have children because in
his view
then they wouldn't be born into this
world of suffering and eventually titans
would cease to exist
while aaron reveals that he only played
along so he could use zeke for his
own ends aaron's plan was to wipe out
the rest of the world and
in doing so save the people who bore and
raised him
the people of paradise island zeke then
in turn reveals
that he was prepared for aaron to
backstab him and that he learned to
nullify the vow to renounce
war and so he was now a royal blooded
eldian who was in a position to command
emir
who could unleash every titan power you
can imagine at this point
zeke in theory could have unleashed the
rumbling some in past time shifters like
aaron would go on to do later
and much much more at this point he was
the strongest being in the world because
he could command
the strongest being in the world emir
fritz who he thought would remain a
slave with no will of her own
however aaron eventually helped snap
emir out of her slave mentality and of
her own free will she decided to lend
her power to the non-royal blooded aaron
who absorbed zeke's power into his own
and later used zeke's beast titan to
destroy enemy aircrafts
without a doubt aaron is currently the
strongest titan shifter we've seen to
date and it's all because he convinced
amir the founder
to go along with his plan rather than
zeke's and so that is zeke's insane
journey
he started out as marleigh's strongest
warrior a very impressive accomplishment
considering the past beast titan wasn't
even fit for battle
then for a second he had the greatest
power imaginable within his reach
and was even unaffected by king karl
fritz's ideology but he mistakenly
took amir for a mindless slave while
aaron saw her as a human with free will
and that made all the difference and
allowed aaron to gain the ultimate titan
power instead of zeke
at his strongest in theory zeke was
stronger than levi and he even came out
the winner in their latest clash
because he fully and quickly recovered
while levi never fully recovered
but that was when he had amir fritz
serving him
and now that emir is no longer a slave
to the royal family
zeke will be significantly weaker if
he's ever separated from aaron's giant
skeletal titan
and that is it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it thank you so much for
watching and staying tuned until the end
if you did like it
then i would really appreciate it if you
could warhammer smash that like button
really destroy it
that will let me know that you guys want
to see more attack on time videos like
this one and drop a suggestion
for what titan shifter you would like me
to cover next in this way
in the comments if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select all or
you will miss future attack on time
videos and while you wait for the next
video to drop
feel free to check out my growing attack
on time playlist where we got videos
about all the titan shifters
and their powers all the acronyms and
their powers the times rank for weakest
to strongest and much
much more link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans ingrata the world
acquire respect pate heffarithian
emperor otaku spidey life tinel fake
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazowski joel stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fond ruthu and aura alicia
actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water floreon
joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz anthony schreiber
hi jinx and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you